* Rhythmische, elektronische Klänge *
Innerhalb von 2 Sek.,
wenn überhaupt,
sind meine Waffen
auch gebrauchsfähig.
* Rhythmische, elektronische Klänge *
Ich wollte aufspringen
und in dem Moment knallte es.
Er hatte sich
in den Kopf geschossen.
* Rhythmische, elektronische Klänge *
Es gibt einem
eine gewisse Sicherheit,
niemandem
schutzlos ausgeliefert zu sein.
* Rhythmische, elektronische Klänge *
Dass ich für mich selber
eine Waffe wollte,
begann damit, was um mich herum
alles passiert ist.
* Knall *
(Mann) Sehr gut.
Immer schön mit Gefühl auslösen.
Einmal im Jahr schlagen in Lausanne
die Herzen der Waffenliebhaber höher.
Es sind v.a. Männer,
die es an die Waffenbörse zieht.
Wer will, kann hier gleich
einen Waffenerwerbsschein beantragen.
Fast in allen Kantonen
haben die Gesuche für
den Waffenerwerb stark zugenommen.
Hansruedi Dahinden besitzt bereits
mehrere Pistolen und Revolver,
nicht zuletzt für seine Sicherheit,
wie er sagt.
Dahinden, von allen nur Dadi genannt,
ist seit seiner Zeit im Militär
von Waffen fasziniert.
Damals habe man noch stolz
auf die Armee sein können, sagt er.
Heute sei das anders.
Das Militär ist wohl nicht wirklich
dafür da, um uns zu beschützen.
Darum, denke ich,
müssen wir uns selber beschützen.
Gewehre, die man im Liegen schiesst,
kann er wegen Knieproblemen
nicht mehr benützen.
Früher hatte ich
auch ein Maschinengewehr.
Das konnte ich im Militär
dann gegen eine Pistole eintauschen.
Heute kann ich fast nicht aufstehen,
wenn ich einmal liege.
Deshalb kommt so etwas
gar nicht infrage.
Was fasziniert Sie an Waffen?
Das Schiessen an sich. Der Schuss.
* Monotone, elektronische Klänge *
In seinem Schlafzimmer
bewahrt der zweifache Familienvater
seine Schiesseisen auf.
Wenn ich bedroht wäre, müsste ich
wohl nicht allzu lange überlegen.
Dann würde ich sehr wahrscheinlich
auch zur Waffe greifen.
Nicht nur, um mich selber zu
verteidigen, ich habe auch Familie.
Auch früher, als unsere Kinder
noch kleiner waren, sagte ich immer:
"Wehe dem, der meine Tochter
anfasst, der macht das nur einmal."
Und dann würde ich sehr wahr-
scheinlich schon zur Waffe greifen.
Ja, dieses Gewehr
schiesst also nicht schlecht.
* Knall *
Germain Spielmann ist Büchsenmacher
im st. gallischen Schänis.
Seine Spezialität:
Sturmgewehre veredeln.
Das sind unsere Sturmgewehre 57
mit neuen Läufen, die wir machen.
Die Visierungen sind so präpariert,
dass nichts mehr locker ist.
Das ist also eine richtige
Präzisionswaffe geworden,
mit der unsere Kunden
sehr erfolgreich schiessen
und auch sehr viel Freude
erleben können.
Ich sage:
Ich verkaufe hier Lebensqualität.
Die Lebensqualität sieht Spielmann
aber grundsätzlich bedroht.
Die Welt habe sich
zum Schlechten verändert, meint er.
Leider setzten natürlich
auch die Bösen die Waffen ein,
um andere zu beherrschen.
Darum fände ich es gut,
wenn wir bewaffnet wären.
Denn erst wenn wir bewaffnet sind,
haben wir das Gegenrecht
oder dieselbe Macht
wie ein Krimineller,
der sich vorher
mit bösen Absichten bewaffnet.
Dem sind wir schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Sie meinen,
jeder sollte in der Schweiz
mit einer Waffe herumlaufen dürfen?
Ja, ich finde, es wäre gut,
wenn jeder Respekt vor der Waffe
und dem Mitmenschen hätte.
Denn in letzter Zeit - gerade
durch den Rückgang der Armee -
hat man einfach das Gefühl,
es sei nichts mehr da.
Aber das könnte
zu Gewaltexzessen führen.
Denn wenn man bei einem Konflikt
die Waffe dabei hat, zückt man diese.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Wenn man ausgebildet ist -
dazu ist grosse Körperbeherrschung
nötig -,
wird man eine Waffe
nicht missbrauchen.
Man weiss,
was die Waffe an Bösem leisten kann.
Aber davor hat man auch Respekt.
* Fröhliche Latin Music *
Unbeschwert durchs Leben tanzen,
fernab von Angst und Sorgen.
Doch wenn die Füsse still stehen,
sind sich die Kursteilnehmerinnen
und Kursteilnehmer einig:
Das Leben ist keine Party.
Wir waren sogar schon einmal in
so einer Situation - vor Jahren -,
dass jemand eingebrochen ist.
Dann holt man halt das Nächstbeste,
einen Bickel oder eine Schaufel.
Denn dann kommt der Urinstinkt.
Das war bei dir auch so.
Genau.
Da wurde eingebrochen und ich ...
Ich habe automatisch ...
Da schlief noch
unser kleines Patenkind bei uns.
Ich nahm den Gegenstand
und lief durchs Haus.
Zum eigenen Schutz.
- Genau.
Es war dann zwar niemand mehr da.
- Er war schon wieder weg.
Bei uns war das in Spanien mit
meiner Schwester im Nachbarhaus so.
Mein Schwager rief an und fragte, ob
er mit dem Hund rüberkommen könne.
Er ging rüber und ich, mit den klei-
nen Kindern, holte ein Rüstmesser.
Gaby Niggli sagt,
sie fühle sich zu Hause
nicht mehr so sicher wie früher.
Auslöser war der Vierfachmord
im aargauischen Rupperswil.
Die medizinische Pflegeassistentin
wohnt unweit des Tatortes.
Ich möchte mir für meine Sicherheit
eine Waffe zulegen.
Ich hatte diesen Gedanken
schon vor einigen Jahren,
dass ich
etwas haben oder machen muss,
wenn meine Kinder alle weg sind.
Damit ich mich
nicht mehr so alleine fühle.
Mein Mann arbeitet in der Nacht
häufig, dann bin ich auch alleine.
Damit ich hier zu Hause
Sicherheit habe, falls etwas ist.
Denn es ist so viel passiert,
auch ganz nahe in der Umgebung,
wo dieser Mord geschah.
Es passiert einfach immer mehr
mit den offenen Grenzen etc.
Das bereitet mir schon Sorgen.
Ich möchte mich hier zu Hause
einfach sicher fühlen.
Frau Niggli, was machen Sie,
wenn Sie nachts alleine zu Hause sind
und jemand an Tür klingelt?
Dann würde ich,
glaube ich, meine Waffe holen
und dann an der Tür
erst mal fragen, wer da ist.
Und wenn ich
keine Antwort bekomme ...
Ich würde sie
vielleicht hier hinten halten.
(Laut) Wer ist da?
Wenn ich keine Antwort bekäme,
würde ich nicht öffnen.
Diese Waffe gibt mir Sicherheit.
Denn wenn jemand
die Tür einfach aufreissen würde,
dann wüsste ich, dass ich dem
die Waffe zeigen könnte.
Und notfalls
würden Sie auch schiessen?
Ich glaube schon.
Wenn es um mein Leben geht.
Mit ihrem Bedürfnis
eine Waffe zu kaufen,
ist sie nicht alleine.
Im vergangenen Jahr
stiegen erneut in fast allen Kantonen
die Gesuche für Waffenerwerbsscheine.
Uri und Genf
verzeichneten fast 50 % mehr Anträge.
Zu den Spitzenreitern
zählt auch der Kanton Aargau.
Hier gingen
über 40 % mehr Gesuche ein.
Man stellte fest,
dass die Anzahl Waffenerwerbsscheine
in den letzten Jahren gestiegen ist.
Insbesondere erkundigen sich
auch immer mehr Frauen
nach einem Waffenerwerbsschein
und lassen einen ausstellen.
Aber es ist schwierig zu sagen,
was der Grund dafür ist,
dass gerade Frauen
eine Waffe anschaffen wollen.
Da kann ich
keine Begründung abgeben.
Peter Meier
ist fasziniert von Waffen.
Er kauft sich
immer wieder einmal eine dazu.
Seinen Schatz bunkert er im Keller.
Er hat einen Wert von über 20'000 Fr.
Zur Sicherheit habe ich
eine spezielle Türsicherung.
Das ist mal das
und hier das normale Schloss.
Hier im Stahlrahmen sind Zacken
und hier sind Löcher.
Es ist also
sehr schwierig aufzubrechen.
Das ist nun meine Revolversammlung.
Hier mein Paradestück:
ein Freedom-Arms-Revolver,
ein sog. Single-Action.
* Klicken *
Eine spezielle Waffe:
Das ist ein Perkussionsrevolver.
Diesen hält man so.
Damals
schoss man natürlich einhändig.
* Klicken *
Bäng.
Das ist ein sehr seltener Revolver.
Das Besondere ist, dass man
die Patronen selber machen kann.
Ausserdem
ist das doch eine schöne Waffe.
Der Griff ist aus Nussbaum,
glaube ich.
Ein wunderschöner Griff.
46 Waffen zieren seine Sammlung.
Etliche
benützt er an Schiesswettbewerben.
Ich weiss,
manche Leute kriegen schon Zustände,
wenn sie das Wort Waffe nur hören.
Aber für mich
sind das keine Waffen in dem Sinne.
Sie sehen hier nirgends
Trophäen mit Hirschgeweih.
Meine einzigen Trophäen sind
Goldmedaillen und Auszeichnungen.
Meier sammelt nicht nur Waffen,
sondern auch Munition
und die dazu passende Literatur.
Klar, Kriegsführung
interessiert mich schon auch.
Das sind 9-mm-Geschosse -
Hollow Point.
Schiesst man damit in die Schulter,
gibt es einen glatten Durchschuss
und wenn dahinter jemand steht, kann
dieser tödlich getroffen werden.
* Gemächliches Jodellied:
"E gschänkte Tag" von Adolf Stähli *
# ... git es Tage,
wo di nüt me fröit.
# De vergiss im Läbe nie ...
Germain Spielmann ist nicht nur
wegen der Freude am Singen
Mitglied eines Jodelvereins.
Dem 56-jährigen geht es v.a. um
die Erhaltung der Schweizer Kultur.
Wir haben immer weniger Mitglieder.
V.a. junge Mitglieder fehlen.
Die Vereine in der Schweiz
müssen um Nachwuchs kämpfen.
Trotzdem ist die Zuwanderung hoch,
es sind viele Leute hier.
Es kann sehr gefährlich werden,
wenn ein grosser Teil
der Bevölkerung
sich nicht mehr
am sozialen Austausch beteiligt.
Leute, die zugewandert sind,
können sich in keinem Verein finden.
Aber gerade sie sollten sich zur
Integration in die Vereine begeben.
Sonst gibt es nie eine Integration,
sondern eine Zweiklassen-
oder Schattengesellschaft,
eine doppelte Gesellschaft,
in der sie ihr Leben führen
und wir unser Kulturgut
pflegen müssen,
aber immer mehr
zur Seite gedrängt werden.
* Bedächtiger Jodel *
Auch Dadi Dahinden
fühlt sich in seiner Heimat
immer mehr zur Seite gedrängt.
* Surren *
Was ist Ihr Idealbild der Schweiz?
So wie es vor 20-30 Jahren war.
Damals waren wir viel freier,
sicherer und ruhiger.
Das alles ist heute nicht mehr so.
Zeitlebens schon
wohnt er im selben Dorf.
Nach der Schulzeit
lernte er Heizungssanitär.
Später
arbeitete er in einer Giesserei.
Wegen Rückenproblemen musste Dahinden
seine Arbeit aufgeben.
Und so wurde er im Alter
von 57 Jahren zum IV-Bezüger.
Heute, mit 66,
blickt er sorgenvoll in die Zukunft.
Wir haben zu viele Ausländer
in der Schweiz.
Es ist jenseits von Gut und Böse.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, die Schweiz
werde dadurch unsicherer?
Sie ist schon unsicherer geworden.
Viel unsicherer.
Früher waren wir hier sicherer.
Es kann auch bei uns
etwas passieren, aber ...
Bei so vielen Ausländern
haben viele Leute Angst.
Und zwar sehr grosse Angst.
Ist diese Angst denn berechtigt?
Haben Sie selber
schon etwas Negatives erlebt?
Nein, ich nicht.
Aber vielleicht traut man sich
nicht, mich anzugreifen.
Wurde denn jemand aus
Ihrem Bekanntenkreis angegriffen?
Nein, aber wenn man fernsieht
und Zeitung liest,
ist man gleich orientiert.
Und ich glaube nicht,
dass sie in der Presse
nur Scheissdreck schreiben.
Es muss etwas dran sein.
Seine Einschätzung,
alles werde immer schlimmer,
steht im Widerspruch zur Statistik.
Seit mehreren Jahren sinken in der
Schweiz die registrierten Straftaten.
Beispielsweise der Kanton Aargau:
Hier wurden 2016
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
10 % weniger Delikte begangen.
Trotzdem glauben viele,
dass die Kriminalität zunehme.
Die Medienberichterstattung
hat heute auch einen Einfluss.
Wenn es im öffentlichen Raum
eine Gewaltstraftat gibt,
wird das durch die verschiedenen
Medienkanäle multipliziert:
Zeitungen,
Radio und soziale Netzwerke.
Das ergibt einen Multiplikator und
die Leute fühlen sich unsicherer,
obwohl es nur eine Straftat ist.
Die Straftaten
nehmen laut Kriminalstatistik ab.
Aber statt sich sicherer zu fühlen,
wird man verunsichert.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das stimmt.
Aber es ist so:
Sowohl bei der Ausländerkriminalität
wie auch bei der allgemeinen
Kriminalitätsstatistik
sind die Zahlen rückläufig.
Mhm.
Also für mich ist es ganz anders,
was ich höre und sehe ...
Für mich wird es immer schlimmer.
* Rhythmische, sphärische Klänge *
Im bernischen Burgdorf
besucht die 46-Jährige
das Waffengeschäft von Daniel Wyss,
um sich beraten zu lassen.
Beim Revolver würde man
die Patrone einfach hier reinlegen.
Dann schränkt man die Trommel
so ein. Die Waffe ist jetzt geladen.
Um ganz schnell zu schiessen, im
Selbstverteidigungsfall, mache ich:
* Klicken *
Innerhalb eines Sekundenbruchteils
kann ich durchziehen
und dann knallt es bereits.
Bei einem Revolver kann man auch
potenziell nicht tödliche Patronen,
sog. Mannstopp-Patronen
verschiessen.
Dann gibt es einfach
einen sehr kräftigen Schlag,
wie einen starken Faustschlag.
Dazu gibt es einfach
einen wichtigen Punkt:
Wenn man eine Faustfeuerwaffe
im äussersten Fall
wirklich
zur Verteidigung einsetzen will,
muss man im Umgang damit
ganz sicher sein.
Und Sie müssen die Gesetzgebung
kennen, das Notwehrrecht,
um zu wissen,
wann Sie überhaupt schiessen dürfen.
Ich hörte mal, man sollte einfach
nicht in den Rücken schiessen.
Ja, vom Notwehrrecht her
wäre das sicher ganz falsch.
Denn Sie dürfen ja
nur auf jemanden schiessen,
von dem
eine tödliche Gefahr ausgeht.
Wenn der Sie also
direkt tödlich angreift.
Zum Kauf einer Faustfeuerwaffe
konnte sich Gaby Niggly
noch nicht entschliessen.
Sie muss ohnehin zuerst einen Auszug
aus dem Strafregister beantragen.
Das geht dann an den Kanton.
Dieser prüft
den Strafregisterauszug,
das Polizeiregister,
den Bericht der Gemeinde.
Und dann wird der Waffenerwerbs-
schein ausgestellt oder nicht.
Ablehnungsgründe
wären z.B. mehrfache Vorstrafen,
Alkohol- oder Drogenprobleme
oder wenn man davon ausgehen muss,
dass die Person sich selber
oder andere
mit einer Waffe gefährden würde.
Also bei Drohungen z.B.
Ich möchte Sie hier in Appenzell
ganz herzlich begrüssen.
Ich freue mich, dass ich Sie
auf einer kulinarischen Dorfführung
begleiten darf.
Schiessvereine haben in der Schweiz
eine lange Tradition.
Diese Schützengesellschaft aus Baden
wurde vor 550 Jahren gegründet.
Prost!
- Zum Wohl.
Der Ausflug führt die Gesellschaft
nach Appenzell.
In der Schweiz
gibt es über 3'000 Schiessvereine.
Fast jedes Wochenende
treffen sich deren Mitglieder.
Sie trainieren zusammen und
nehmen an Schiesswettbewerben teil.
Es geht nicht nur um das Technische,
bei uns ums Schiessen,
bei anderen Vereinen um den Sport,
sondern auch um die Gesellschaft,
das Zusammensein, das Dazugehören.
Ist der Zusammenhalt bei Ihnen gut?
Ich denke schon.
Nicht zuletzt, weil wir solche
gemeinsamen Dinge unternehmen.
Das tun wir ganz bewusst.
Die meisten Schützenvereine
verzeichneten in den letzten Jahren
einen Mitgliederschwund.
Weil die Badener
bewusst den Nachwuchs fördern,
sind sie aber nicht davon betroffen.
* Mehrfaches Knallen *
Am nächsten Tag
fliegt Blei durch die Luft.
Scheibe 12.
Auszahlung bereit, gut Schuss!
Mihailo Kinkela
schiesst seit einem Jahr.
Für den 16-jährigen Gymnasiasten
hat das Schiessen etwas Meditatives.
Man findet in diesem Sport
seine innere Ruhe.
Durch diese Konzentration
nur auf das Korn und das Visier
und die ganze Feinmechanik,
die man in den Fingern hat.
Für die Schützen ist Schiessen ein
Sport und das Gewehr ein Sportgerät.
Die restliche Welt
spricht von Waffen,
deren Gebrauch
strenger limitiert werden müsse.
Unter den Schützen herrscht Aufruhr.
Sie erwarten Schlimmes von der EU.
Diese berät
nach den verschiedenen Anschlägen
über strengere Richtlinien.
Davon wäre auch die Schweiz
als Schengen-Staat betroffen.
Die Badener Schützen sind ratlos.
Schärfere Waffenrichtlinien würden
nur die anständigen Bürger bestrafen,
glauben sie.
Ich weiss nicht, was man
noch zusätzlich verlangen will,
was die Schützenvereine
noch tun können.
Man will ja
das Waffengesetz verschärfen.
Man entscheidet in Brüssel,
die Bevölkerung zu entwaffnen,
das sei der einfachste Schritt.
Aber damit werden nur die legalen,
registrierten Waffen
aus dem Verkehr gezogen.
Und nicht die illegalen.
Es gibt mehr solche als legale.
Genau das sage ich.
- Die kann man überall kaufen.
Mit der Verschärfung bestraft man
nur die Jäger, Sportschützen
und Sammler.
Aber die Kriminalität
wird dadurch nicht eingedämmt.
* Pulsierende, sphärische Klänge *
In Brüssel arbeitete man
eineinhalb Jahre lang
an den neuen Feuerwaffenrichtlinien.
Sie beinhalten u.a. ein Verbot
für halbautomatische Waffen
mit mehr als zehn Schuss.
Sportschützen und anerkannte Sammler
sollen aber eine Ausnahmebewilligung
beantragen dürfen.
Sie müssen nachweisen, dass sie
Mitglied eines Schützenvereins sind
und regelmässig
an Schiesswettbewerben teilnehmen.
Es gab ein Problem
mit dem europäischen Gesetz -
da gehört die Schweiz dazu -
mit den vollautomatischen Waffen,
die auf Halbautomatik
umgerüstet werden können.
Sie konnten in der EU ohne Waffen-
schein gekauft und verkauft werden.
Wir haben diese Gesetzeslücke
geschlossen,
weil diese Waffen in die Hände
von Terroristen gelangten.
Vicky Ford arbeitete federführend
an den neuen Richtlinien.
Die Britin ist Präsidentin
des Ausschusses für Binnenmarkt
und Verbraucherschutz.
Sie hält fest, dass für die Schweiz
eine Ausnahmeregelung vorgesehen ist.
So dürfen Soldaten ihr Sturmgewehr
nach geleisteter Dienstpflicht
weiterhin nach Hause nehmen,
wenn sie aktive Sportschützen sind.
Es gibt Verschärfungen
im europäischen Waffengesetz,
aber es liegt
in der Hand der Schweiz,
die Richtlinien
für den Waffengebrauch festzulegen.
Das ist meine Botschaft: Wir
gaben der Schweiz die Möglichkeit,
ihren Bürgern
die Erlaubnis zu erteilen,
wenn sie einen Bedarf
nachweisen können.
Die Schweizer Regierung bestimmt,
nicht das europäische Gesetz.
Mitte März stimmte das EU-Parlament
der neuen Richtlinie zu.
Sie soll 2020 in Kraft treten.
Zwei Jahre später muss die Schweiz
gemäss Schengen-Vertrag nachziehen.
Sie erhält von Brüssel bei der
konkreten Umsetzung viel Freiraum.
Du holst dein Gewehr ab, oder?
- Ja.
Nun ist also Bern am Zug.
Bereits jetzt
mobilisiert sich Widerstand
gegen jegliche Änderung
des bestehenden Waffenrechts.
Politiker wie Jakob Büchler
aus dem Kanton St. Gallen
sind die Hoffnung
von Germain Spielmann.
Der CVP-Nationalrat ist beim Büch-
senmacher ein gern gesehener Gast.
Dieser verspricht,
alles Notwendige zu unternehmen,
um die Gefahr abzuwenden.
Die Schweiz hat damals, 2005, als
das Schengen-Abkommen vors Volk kam,
eine sog. Sonderregelung
ausgehandelt.
Ich gehe davon aus - und
bisher hörte ich nichts anderes -,
dass das nach wie vor gilt.
Ich werde aber
an der nächsten Session
eingehend mit Frau Sommaruga
darüber diskutieren.
Ich will von ihr wissen:
Ist das noch in Kraft?
Gilt das noch weiterhin für uns?
Bisher hörte ich nichts anderes.
Ich gehe davon aus, so sei es.
Wenn es so nicht wäre, dann müssten
wir den politischen Weg beschreiten.
Auch die Basis
bereitet sich auf den Ernstfall vor.
Wir haben
130'000 Schützen in der Schweiz,
die Schiessen
aktiv als Sport betreiben.
Das sind schon 130'000
Unterschriften für das Referendum.
Ausserdem sammelt auch die AUNS.
Chantal Gallade
ist die wohl bekannteste Gegnerin
der Schweizer Waffenszene.
Der Vater der Nationalrätin nahm sich
mit der Armeewaffe das Leben.
Ich wäre auch ohne das Erlebnis,
dass mein Vater sich
mit der Armeewaffe umgebracht hat,
nicht für Schusswaffen zu Hause.
Es ist aber
möglicherweise der Grund,
weshalb ich
immer wieder an der Front stehe,
weil ich selber betroffen bin,
weil ich das selber erlebt habe.
Die SP-Politikerin ist Mitglied der
sicherheitspolitischen Kommission.
Sie wird an vorderster Front
an der Umsetzung der neuen EU-
Richtlinien für die Schweiz arbeiten.
Ich forderte politisch schon immer,
Sportschützen sollen
ihre Schusswaffen haben dürfen,
weil das Sportgeräte sind.
Man kann sich aber fragen,
ob man sie nicht dort lagern soll,
wo man schiesst.
Denn auf dem Heimweg oder zu Hause
können sie ja nichts damit tun.
Aber weil es politisch
nicht möglich ist, das zu ändern,
können Sportschützen sie auch haben.
Es wäre schon
ein riesiger Gewinn an Sicherheit,
wenn nur noch Sportschützen, Jäger
und Polizisten selbstverständlich
Waffen zu Hause hätten.
Schusswaffen nützen im Alltag
nichts, niemand darf sie einsetzen.
Und wenn sie eingesetzt werden,
sind sie eine Gefahr oder töten.
Darum ergibt es keinen Sinn,
dass Menschen im Privathaushalt
eine Schusswaffe haben.
Die Schweiz hat eine
der höchsten Waffendichten pro Kopf.
Sie steht an vierter Stelle hinter
den USA, dem Jemen und Serbien.
2 Mio. Schusswaffen werden
in Schweizer Haushalten aufbewahrt,
schätzt der Bund.
Davon eine 500'000 Armeewaffen.
Ein Armeegewehr war es auch,
mit dem sich der Ehemann von Doris L.
das Leben nahm.
Mein Mann
war die Liebe meines Lebens.
Und gleichzeitig ist er mittlerweile
auch das Trauma meines Lebens.
Das darf man schon so sagen.
Der Mann von Doris L.
war Offizier im Militär
und bewahrte seine Waffe daheim auf.
Markus L. litt an Depressionen
und war suizidal veranlagt.
Wir hatten an jenem Abend
eine Diskussion
und ich sagte ihm,
so gehe es für mich nicht weiter.
Er müsse sich Hilfe suchen.
Er ging ins Schlafzimmer
und kam mit dem Sturmgewehr zurück.
Als er mit der Waffe kam,
dachte ich, ich müsse sterben.
Das war das Erste,
was mir durch den Kopf ging.
Denn es stand auch
sehr viel Wut in seinem Gesicht.
Und das sind dann Millisekunden,
wenn ein Mensch sich erschiesst.
Also, wenn man das so miterlebt.
Er setzt die Waffe an,
es knallt und dann ist geschossen.
Und je nachdem, wo er trifft,
sinkt er in sich zusammen.
Was man dann selber erlebt,
kann man kaum erklären.
Ich weiss nur noch, dass ich
eine unbestimmte Zeit dasass
und einfach schrie.
Irgendwann
setzte der Verstand wieder ein,
ich hatte ja
noch zwei kleine Kinder.
Ich rannte dann aus der Wohnung
und holte Hilfe.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
In der Trauerphase konnte ich
anfangs gar nicht traurig sein,
sondern da kam sehr viel Wut.
Auch heute werde ich
immer dann noch wütend,
wenn es um meine Kinder geht,
die ja auch seine Kinder sind.
Da müssen Entscheidungen gefällt
werden. Jetzt wird es emotional.
Da werde ich dann sehr wütend,
weil er mich einfach ...
... stehen liess
und mit den Kindern alleine liess.
* Düstere, tragende Klänge *
Solche Tragödien
möchte Chantal Gallade verhindern.
Hallo.
Guten Tag, Herr Spielmann,
willkommen.
Auf unsere Initiative hin hat sich
die Politikerin bereit erklärt,
sich mit Germain Spielmann
zu treffen.
Der Büchsenmacher
und Vertreter der Waffenszene
wird von seiner Lebenspartnerin
begleitet.
Von den ca. 200 -
früher 400 - Schusswaffentoten
ist ein grosser Teil Suizid.
Das macht es nicht weniger schlimm.
- Nein, sicher nicht.
Jeder Schusswaffentote
ist einer zu viel.
Man weiss: Jemand, der Gedanken hat,
aus dem Leben auszuscheiden,
aus dieser Welt zu gehen,
geht früher oder später so oder so.
Ich finde,
jemand, der sich mit einer Waffe -
sei es im Keller
oder in einem Zimmer - umbringt,
ist besser umgebracht,
als wenn er auf die Schiene rennt
und ein unschuldiger Lokführer
dann von der Justiz angezeigt wird
wegen fahrlässiger Tötung,
obwohl er nichts tun konnte.
Und das passiert praktisch täglich.
Sie täuschen sich:
Wenn wir die 200 wegbekommen,
weil wir
die Schusswaffen vernichten,
gehen diese 200 woanders hin.
Sie sagen, einer, der sich
umbringen wolle, tue das sowieso.
Ein Grossteil schon.
- Das ist eben nicht wahr.
Das zeigen Befragungen von Menschen,
die einen Suizidversuch überlebten.
Wenn sie sich im Affekt töten
wollten und man sie retten konnte -
sie waren also nicht tot -,
dann wiederholen das viele nicht.
* Drückende, pulsierende Klänge *
Ich kann unabhängig von ihm sagen,
dass ich der Meinung bin:
Wer in Besitz einer Waffe
und suizidal ist,
braucht diese Waffe
auch viel eher dafür,
als wenn man sich
noch fortbewegen müsste,
also auf eine Brücke klettern,
runterspringen,
sich unter den Zug legen.
Dafür braucht es einfach noch mehr.
Und ich denke, mit einer Waffe
ist es noch Kurzschluss per se.
Ein Suizid
ist immer ein Kurzschluss,
aber mit einer Waffe
macht man es einfach viel schneller.
* Knall *
Es ist schon kein Spielzeug.
Und das ist es, was mich fasziniert.
Ich muss es immer so sagen:
Es ist mit allem dasselbe -
mit Waffen, Geld und den Frauen:
Wer nicht damit umgehen kann,
sollten es sein lassen.
Scheibe 5:
dreimal zehn, zweimal acht.
Als Obmann eines Pistolenklubs
achtet Dadi Dahinden darauf,
dass im Schiessstand
die Vorschriften eingehalten werden.
Jetzt ist sie geladen.
Aber in gewissen Situationen
würde er seine persönliche Sicherheit
über das Gesetz stellen.
Nehmen wir an, ich müsse zur Bank,
um 50'000 Fr. zu holen.
Dann frage ich niemanden,
ob ich die Waffe oder den Revolver
bei mir tragen soll.
Dann tun Sie es einfach?
- Ja, dann tut man das einfach.
Aber nach heutigem Gesetz
wäre das ja illegal.
Natürlich ist es illegal.
Aber was ist heute nicht illegal?
Nein, ich muss einfach sagen:
Auch wenn einer eine Waffe trägt ...
Bei mir
wäre die Hemmschwelle so hoch ...
Ich würde sie vielleicht schon
ziehen, aber mit dem leeren Magazin.
* Knall *
Peter Meier
ist gleich in zwei Vereinen Mitglied.
Regelmässig trainiert er
im Schützenhaus Härdli
in Spreitenbach für Wettkämpfe.
Das ist, wie wenn man
eine gute Arbeit erledigt hat,
die einen zufriedenstellt.
Mit einem guten Schiessresultat
ist man auch zufrieden.
Danach hat man das Bier
in der Schützenstube verdient.
Wer braucht Munition?
Du?
- Ja.
Im Schiessstand ist Meier der Chef.
Als Schützenmeister hat er das Sagen.
Das wären 10 Fr. Vielen Dank.
Was tust du hier?
Ich bin mit Mama und Papa hier.
- Aha.
Aber heute trainiert Würenlos,
nicht Spreitenbach.
Ich schiesse nicht für Spreitenbach.
- Für wen dann?
Für Baden. Papa und Mama sagten,
dass ich wohl schiessen darf.
Baden schiesst aber mittwochs.
Ich weiss. Mama und Papa sagten es.
Ich muss da zuerst wissen,
wer er ist, wie er heisst
und wer Mama und Papa sind.
Klar.
Es kommen manchmal Leute
fragen und schauen.
Da kann nicht einfach jeder
reinkommen und tun, was er will.
Als Schützenmeister muss man
gewissenhaft sein, sagt Meier.
Denn jeder Vorfall
mit einer Schusswaffe
werfe sofort ein schlechtes Licht
auf alle Schützen.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Wenige Kilometer
vom Schützenhaus entfernt,
im Wald
der aargauischen Gemeinde Fislisbach.
An dieser Stelle
erschoss im vergangenen Sommer
ein 17-Jähriger
einen 18-jährigen Kollegen.
Es stellte sich heraus, dass der
Täter ein ehemaliger Jungschütze war.
Im Schützenhaus Härdli
in Spreitenbach
treffen sich die Jungschützen,
um Gewehre zu putzen.
Dass ein ehemaliger Jungschütze
aus der Region
mit seiner Waffe seinen Kollegen
tötete, beschäftigt die Jungen.
Ich verfolgte nicht alles mit,
ich weiss nicht,
woher der die Waffe hatte.
Aber vom Schiessverein
sollte sie nicht sein.
Warum nicht?
Die Jungen behalten die Waffen hier.
Über 16-Jährige
dürfen die Waffe heimnehmen,
aber der Verschluss, den man
zum Schiessen brauch, bleibt hier.
Also sollte so etwas
nicht möglich sein.
Es ist einfach tragisch. Man lernt
hier den Umgang mit dem Sportgerät.
Und dann passiert so etwas.
Das sollte eben nicht passieren.
Sie nennen es ein Sportgerät, aber
das kann eine tödliche Waffe sein.
Ich nehme an,
dessen ist man sich schon bewusst.
Dessen ist man sich bewusst.
Dafür gibt es auch Regeln,
die wir befolgen.
Und Sicherheitsvorschriften,
die regelmässig überprüft werden.
Bei Jugendlichen
boomt der Schiesssport.
Fast 10'000 Teilnehmerinnen
und Teilnehmer
absolvierten im vergangenen Jahr
einen Jungschützenkurs.
Ein Drittel mehr als 2015.
Was ist denn
die Faszination am Schiessen?
Ähm, alles.
Nur schon der Geruch, wenn das
Pulver verdampft, also verbrennt.
Nur schon das.
Aber eigentlich alles.
Im vergangenen Jahr wurde
das Mindestalter für Jungschützen
von 17 auf 15 gesenkt.
Germain Spielmann würde
noch viel Jüngeren eine Waffe geben.
Im Kindergarten muss man einem Kind
beibringen, was eine Waffe ist.
Dass das etwas ist,
was es nicht berühren soll,
womit es nichts zu tun hat.
Es muss natürlich ein Lehrplan sein.
Mit dem Schiessen
beginnt man erst später.
In welchem Alter denn?
Wann soll ein Kind schiessen lernen?
Wenn Sie jetzt einen Lehrplan
für Schusswaffen machen?
Es ist in der Natur des Menschen,
immer etwas zu tun.
Besonders Jungen, aber je länger
je mehr auch Mädchen, wollen wissen,
was eine Schusswaffe ist.
Eine Schusswaffe
ist einfach ein mechanisches Gerät,
das bei falscher Bedienung
gefährlich sein kann.
Darum spreche ich vom Kindergarten.
Denn viele Eltern
haben vielleicht etwas zu Hause.
Manchmal nicht einmal böswillig.
Denn die Kinder stöbern
überall umher. Auch im Estrich.
Darum sollen die Schusswaffen
nicht im Estrich sein.
Das können Sie nicht verhindern.
Also soll im Kindergarten
die Waffenausbildung anfangen?
Dann kommen sie in die Schule, und
unruhigen Kindern gibt man Ritalin.
Und Sie gäben ihnen
eine Schusswaffe?
Ich gäbe ihnen eine Waffe,
resp. eine Form einer Waffe,
mit der sie
das Zielen lernen können.
Man könnte sie einfach umher rennen
und sich bewegen lassen.
Wieso wollen Sie einem Kind zum
Abreagieren eine Schusswaffe geben?
Nicht zum Abreagieren,
sondern es ist eine Ausbildung.
Von mir aus gesehen
würde das dazugehören.
Für Erst- und Zweitklässler.
- Ja, und dann fährt man weiter.
Das Kind macht dann auch
einen pädagogischen Fortschritt.
Ich habe ein anderes Verständnis
von Kindererziehung.
Diese Logik
erschliesst sich mir nicht.
Eine Schusswaffe hat nie
etwas in Kinderhänden verloren.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Waffen begleiten den Menschen
schon seit jeher.
Peter Meier schaut sich
im Landesmuseum Zürich
die Geschichte von 3'500 Jahren an.
Die Waffe ist ein Kulturgut.
Man sieht ja schon:
3'500 Jahre v. Chr. hatte man Waffen
und auch heute hat man Waffen.
Dieses Gen hat sich irgendwie
entwickelt in der Menschheit.
Man entwickelte,
konstruierte Waffen, um zu jagen.
Aber schon damals gab es Stämme,
die einander bekriegten.
Dann setzte man natürlich dieselben
Waffen, mit denen man Tiere jagte,
gegen den Gegner ein - zwangsläufig.
Seine eigenen Kulturschätze
hortet Meier im Keller.
In der Wohnung sind sie tabu.
Salut.
Seiner Frau zuliebe.
Ja, gibst du mir die Hälfte?
Hast du die Einkaufsliste gemacht?
- Ja. - Okay.
Seit 48 Jahren
sind die beiden verheiratet.
Also das Waffensammeln
finden Sie nicht gut?
Nicht unbedingt, nein.
- Warum denn?
Ein bisschen ist in Ordnung.
Aber wenn es zu viel ist ...
Ich gehe sehr ungern in den Keller.
Macht es Ihnen Angst?
- Ja ...
Nicht unbedingt Angst,
aber ich habe ein mulmiges Gefühl.
Seit seiner Pensionierung hat der
75-Jährige viel Zeit für sein Hobby.
Einmal in der Woche
arbeitet er noch als Instruktor
in einem Schiesskeller.
Oft nimmt er erfolgreich
an Wettkämpfen teil.
Seine Munition stellt er selber her.
Wie viel Zeit verbringen Sie
hier unten in Ihrem Raum?
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Ich bin sicher mehrere Stunden
pro Tag hier unten.
Mein Ablauf ist etwa so: Ich komme
vielleicht um 10 Uhr morgens runter,
gehe um 13 Uhr hoch zum Mittagessen
und dann gehe ich wieder runter.
Die "Tagesschau"
ist für mich eine wichtige Sendung,
also bin ich um 19.30 Uhr oben.
Danach gehe ich
nicht mehr in den Keller.
Ausser es gäbe etwas Wichtiges,
was ich am Tag darauf wegen
eines Schiessens noch bräuchte.
Sie sind
ein Waffenkenner und -sammler.
Kann man auch sagen, Sie seien
ein bisschen ein Waffennarr?
Waffennarr -
dieses Wort höre ich nicht gerne.
Es gibt sicher Waffennarren,
aber ich zähle mich nicht dazu.
Und der grösste Teil der Schützen,
die den Schiesssport
seriös betreiben -
wenn man die Waffennarren nennt,
ist das eine Beleidigung.
* Pulsierende, elektronische Klänge *
Aber es gibt sie, Waffennarren.
So geht das.
Da braucht man gute Ohren.
Dieser Mann besitzt über 40 Waffen.
Ein paar stehen bei ihm daheim
geladen herum.
Ist es nicht gefährlich,
eine geladene Waffe?
Z.B. wenn ein Enkel kommt
oder sonst jemand?
Ach, die sind gut erzogen.
Wir sind eher sicherer, weil wir
wissen, dass wir uns wehren können.
Ist es für Sie wichtig, zu wissen,
dass Sie Waffen zu Hause haben
und sich wehren können?
- Ja.
Als sie mir die Waffe wegnahmen,
konnte ich nicht mehr schlafen.
Warum nahm man sie Ihnen weg?
Eben, weil ich angeblich
so einen Linksextremen bedroht habe.
Also was konkret?
Ich schickte ihm zwei Patronen.
Zwei Kugeln.
Warum?
Weil er immer
so schmutzige Artikel schrieb.
Gegen die Rechten.
Und v.a. gegen Blocher.
Aber jemandem Patronen zu schicken,
ist schon etwas krass, oder?
Das ist Geschmackssache.
Für mich ist das nichts Besonderes.
Nachdem ein Psychiater
den Mann begutachtet hatte,
erhielt er seine Waffen
wieder zurück.
Was hat der Psychiater festgestellt?
Am Schluss stand da: "Die Waffen
können wieder erteilt werden."
"Ohne jegliche Gefährdung."
Stell dir doch mal vor! Ich bin doch
viel normaler als die alle zusammen.
Das sage ich auch heute noch.
War das denn einfach
ein Scherz, ein Jux?
Nein, ich habe es
eigentlich schon getan ...
Man darf ja auch versuchen,
Leute zu belehren, oder?
* Leiser Pfeifton *
Das ist der Aufbewahrungsraum
für die sichergestellten Waffen.
Zum konkreten Fall
nehmen die Behörden keine Stellung.
Mediensprecher Roland Pfister
erklärt indes,
unter welchen Bedingungen
jemand beschlagnahmte Waffen
wieder zurückerhält.
Damit jemand
seine Waffe zurückbekommt,
darf von ihm
keine Gefahr mehr ausgehen.
Die Abklärung dafür ist langwierig.
Es kann
ein psychiatrisches Gutachten geben,
das beurteilt, dass die Person
nicht mehr gefährlich ist.
Ein Beschuldigter oder Betroffener
kann immer Rechtsmittel ergreifen,
was in so einem Verfahren
angewandt wird.
Und am Schluss
gibt es so eine Beurteilung.
Wenn die Waffe aufgrund
einer unabhängigen Beurteilung
zurückgegeben wird, kann man zu
einem grossen Teil davon ausgehen,
dass keine Gefahr mehr besteht.
Aber ein Restrisiko
besteht natürlich trotzdem.
* Ruhige, rhythmische Musik *
Schauen wir mal:
Das sind alles auch Waffen.
Am Schluss muss jede Schweizer
Hausfrau ihre Rüstmesser abgeben.
Nur um zu sagen: Auch jedes Messer,
wenn man ganz hart sein will,
jede Faust und jeder Hammer
ist auch eine Waffe.
Man kann auch jemanden
mit der Faust zu Tode schlagen.
Natürlich können andere Gegenstände
auch als Waffen eingesetzt werden.
Das Küchenmesser wird immer genannt.
Nur haben diese einen Zweck im All-
tag, man muss sie nicht verbieten.
Im Gegensatz zur Schusswaffe,
braucht man das Messer im Haushalt.
Man kann nicht
alle Restrisiken ausschliessen.
Ich sage nur: Wo kein Zweck gegeben
ist, wie bei der Schusswaffe,
macht ein Verbot Sinn, weil
sie keinen anderen Zweck haben.
Gaby Niggli hat sich entschieden:
Sie will sich notfalls schützen
können und kauft sich eine Pistole.
So, wollen Sie sie mal halten?
- Ja.
Also,
der Finger muss hier oben sein.
Genau, Sie halten sie richtig.
Die Finger gestreckt.
Und jetzt könnte ich ...
- Sie können zum Versuch ...
Es geht nicht.
Sie müssten den Finger
gerade halten, nie drin.
Vielleicht ... Genau.
Einfach nicht drin.
Versuchen Sie nochmals,
kräftig zu ziehen!
Den Finger nicht im Abzug.
- Das mache ich automatisch.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das dürfen Sie auf keinen Fall tun.
* Er lacht. *
- Ja, es ist ...
Das müssen Sie 500-mal üben.
Der Finger darf nicht im Abzug sein.
Sondern oben.
- Genau.
Daheim bewahrt die 46-Jährige
ihre Pistole in einem Tresor auf -
unerreichbar für ihre Enkelkinder.
Wie fühlen Sie sich,
im Haushalt eine Waffe zu haben?
Es ist für mich schon
immer noch ein komisches Gefühl,
weil ich sie noch nicht lange habe.
Und ich habe Respekt.
Aber ich fühle mich doch gut,
denn es macht mich sicher.
Sicherheit durch Waffenbesitz,
so wie es in einzelnen Staaten
der USA praktiziert wird:
Das wünscht sich Büchsenmacher
Spielmann für die Schweiz.
Z.B. Lehrer könnten bewaffnet sein.
Oder auch Mitschüler.
Lehrer bewaffnet? Und Schüler?
Dann könnten diese School Shootings
eben nicht passieren.
Man muss so ein durchgeknalltes Kind
halt auch mal umbringen.
Damit es nicht
100 oder 20 andere umbringt.
Da liegt das Problem.
Darf ich darauf eingehen?
- Ja, später.
Das ist auch in Frankreich so,
in diesen Klubs,
wo diese Leute einfach auftraten.
Wären dort
Leute mit Schusswaffen gewesen,
hätte das Endergebnis
vielleicht anders ausgesehen.
Dann könnte man sofort
auf einen Attentäter schiessen.
Dort liegt die Gefahr.
Ihr Menschen- und Sicherheitsbild
macht mir Angst.
Das ist doch absurd.
Das erhöht doch das Risiko,
dass es Tote, Unfälle gibt.
Das ist ja wahnsinnig.
Und dann fühlt sich einer bedroht,
holt sie hervor
und knallt z.B. den Lehrer ab.
Und dann holt der Nächste eine
hervor und erschiesst den Ersten?
Das stellt keine Sicherheit her.
Das wäre der Horror.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Auch wenn
die Kriminalität zurückgeht:
Menschen wie Gaby Niggli sind über-
zeugt, dass die Gefahren zunehmen.
Fakten können dagegen
nichts ausrichten.
Gegen die Macht der Gefühle
ist mancher wehrlos.